S
YOU LOVE.
♪♪
.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY WE
BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT AS
WE SPEAK YOUR PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN IS HEADED TO BEACH IN
DELAWARE, YET AGAIN, FOR ANOTHER
LONG WEEKEND AWAY FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER, HE'S ALREADY SPENT 188
DAYS ON VACATION INCLUDING 130
DAYS IN DELAWARE, 52 AT HIS
PRESIDENTIAL RETREAT, CAMP
DAVID, SIX DAYS IN BEAUTIFUL
NANTUCKET AND IS STEADFASTLY
REFUSING TO RELEASE VISITOR LOGS
FOR MOST OF THESE LOCATIONS.
JOE IS NOW ON PACE TO SPEND WHAT
WOULD BE A WHOOPING 553 DAYS
AWAY FROM THE WHITE HOUSE IN HIS
FIRST AND PROBABLY ONLY TERM.
THAT'S MORE THAN ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT IN THE MODERN ERA.
THIS IS AS MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
ARE NOW SUFFERING FROM A DIRE
BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE, AN
ONGOING SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS,
LOOMING STAG FLAILINGS, ALL 50
STATES RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES
AND THE NATIONWIDE AVERAGE IS
NEARING $5 A GALLON AND GOOD
LUCK GETTING DIESEL BELOW EIGHT
BUCKS A GALLON.
25% OF AMERICANS ARE NOW
DELAYING RETIREMENT BECAUSE OF
JOE'S INFLATION.
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS ARE NOW
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
2 OUT OF EVERY 3 AMERICANS.
YOU THINK THINGS ARE BAD NOW
BUCKLE UP BECAUSE THE FED IS NOW
POISED TO RAISE INTEREST RATES
AGAIN, THIS TIME A FULL POINT
WHICH WILL CAUSE PROPERTY VALUES
MOST PEOPLE'S BIGGEST INVESTMENT
TO PLUMMET AND SEND THIS COUNTRY
STRAIGHT INTO A DEEP RECESSION.
IF YOU ARE ON A FIXED INCOME, IF
YOU'RE IN THE POOR, MIDDLE
CLASS, ALL SUFFERING MISERABLY
BECAUSE OF BIDEN'S NEW GREEN
DEAL SOCIALISM, AND, OF COURSE,
HIS ADHERENCE TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY CLIMATE ALARMISM RELIGIOUS
CONSULT.
IT'S LIKE YOU CAN'T EVEN
DEPROGRAM THESE PEOPLE THEY'RE
SO NUTS.
JOE BIDEN IS HEADED TO THE BEACH
YET AGAIN BUT NOT BEFORE
LECTURING ORDINARY TAX-PAYING
HARD WORKING, LAW ABIDING
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
THREATENING TO RIP AWAY OUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS WHICH HE
THINKS IS NOT ABSOLUTE.
I TEND TO DISAGREE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE SECOND AMENDMENT LIKE ALL
OTHER RIGHTS IS NOT ABSOLUTE.
WE NEED TO BAN ASSAULT WEAPONS
AND HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
AND IF WE CAN'T BAN ASSAULT
WEAPONS, THEN WE SHOULD RAISE
THE AGE TO PURCHASE THEM FROM 18
TO 21.
STRENGTHEN BACKGROUND CHECKS
ENACT SAFE STORAGE LAWS AND RED
FLAG LAWS.
REPEAL THE IMMUNITY THAT
PROTECTS GUN MANUFACTURERS FROM
LIABILITY.
ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
DEEPENING THE TRAUMA OF GUN
VIOLENCE AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT VIOLENCE.
ENOUGH.
MY GOD, THE FACT THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE SENATE
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT ANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS EVEN TO BE
DEBATED OR COME UP FOR A VOTE, I
FIND UNCONSCIONABLE.
MEET THE MOMENT.
LET US FINALLY DO SOMETHING.
>> Sean: NOW, WE LIKE TO USE
JOE'S FAVORITE LANGUAGE, FOR GOD
SAKES JOE, DO SOMETHING.
WELL, FOR GOD SAKES, JOE, I HAVE
A QUESTION.
WHY DIDN'T YOU AND BARACK OBAMA
DO SOMETHING IN EIGHT YEARS TO
STOP THE VIOLENCE IN THE CITY OF
CHICAGO, OBAMA'S HOME TOWN.
WHY NOT JOE?
AND FOR GOD'S SAKE, JOE, WHY DID
YOU NEVER WORN TIME, NOT ONE
TIME, AS VP FOR EIGHT YEARS,
MENTION A SINGLE CHILD'S NAME
KILLED IN OBAMA'S HOME TOWN WHEN
YOU WERE VICE-PRESIDENT?
FOR GOD'S SAKES WHY?
YOU NEVER LIFT I HAD A FINGER
JOE, WHY.
SAVE US THE LECTURES BECAUSE YOU
HAVE BEEN MISSING IN ACTION FOR
ALL OF THESE YEARS.
THIS DIVISIVE SPEECH TONIGHT WAS
NOTHING MORE THAN A POLITICAL
STUNT, PRETTY PREDICTABLE.
LOUISIANA THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND THE NEW GUN CONTROL BILL,
THAT, TOO, IS A POLITICAL STUNT
IN AN ELECTION YEAR.
IT WILL NOT PASS THE SENATE.
THAT DIDN'T STOP ONE FAR LEFT
MEMBER OF CONGRESS FROM OPENLY
FANTASIZING ABOUT HIS PARTY'S
WILDEST DREAMS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ENOUGH OF YOUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS.
ENOUGH.
YOU WILL NOT STOP US FROM
ADVANCING THE PROTECTING OUR
KIDS ACT TODAY.
YOU WILL NOT STOP US FROM
PASSING IT IN THE HOUSE NEXT
WEEK, AND WILL YOU NOT STOP US
THERE.
IF THE FILIBUSTER OBSTRUCTS US,
WE WILL ABOLISH IT.
IF THE SUPREME COURT OBJECTS, WE
WILL EXPAND IT.
AND WE WILL NOT REST UNTIL WE
HAVE TAKEN WEAPONS OF WAR OUT OF
CIRCULATION IN OUR COMMUNITY.
EACH AND EVERY DAY, WE WILL DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO END GUN
VIOLENCE, WHATEVER IT TAKES.
>> Sean: OH, THAT MEANS FULL
AUTHORITARIANISM.
THAT SOUND GREAT.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED,
DEMOCRATS DON'T LIKE OUR SYSTEM
OF CHECKS AND BALANCES, OUR
CONSTITUTION, SOMETHING CALLED
THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
THEY JUST WANT ONE PARTY RULE IN
PERPETUITY FOREVER AND EVER AND
EVER, AND THAT'S WHY THEY WANT
THE COURT PACKING, THEY WANT DC
STATEHOOD, THEY WANT TO END THE
FILIBUSTER AND THEY DON'T WANT
VOTER ID LAWS.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF WANTS TO
DISARM LAWFUL AMERICANS BECAUSE
HE THINKS THE ACCIDENT AMENDMENT
IS ABOUT HUNTING DEAR AND NOT AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT.
JOE BIDEN, WELL, HAS TO BE ONE
OF THE DUMBEST PEOPLE IN DC AND
THAT IS SAYING A LOT.
SO DUMB JOE CAN'T EVEN FIGURE
OUT WHY HIS POLL NUMBERS ARE
CRATERING.
RIGHT NOW HE'S UNDER WATER, LOOK
AT THIS, IN 40 OUT OF 50 STATES.
A NEW REUTERS POLL HAS HIM. A
WHOOPING 36% A BROTHERLY RATING,
ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS HE IS
ABSOLUTELY MYSTIFIED, TOTALLY BY
WILLEDERED ABOUT THESE
PLUMMETING NUMBERS.
HE THINKS IT MIGHT BE A
MESSAGING PROBLEM AND IS BLAMING
HIS STAFF AND POINTING FINGERS
AT THEM.
OF COURSE IT'S NOT A MESSAGING
PROBLEM IT'S A REALITY PROBLEM.
RIGHT NOW EVERY AMERICAN IS
STRUGGLING TO GET BY.
TWO-THIRDS LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK.
AND BY THE WAY, THEY'RE REMINDED
EVERY TIME THEY FILL UP THEIR
TANK THAT THEY'RE PAYING DOUBLE
WHAT THEY PAID UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THEN THEY GOES TO THEIR GROCERY
STORE AND ANY OTHER STORE AND
ARE PAYING ALMOST DOUBLE FOR
EVERYTHING THEY BY INR STORE
THEY GO TO.
UNLESS THEY NEED BABY FORMULA,
THEN THEY HAVE TO DRIVE FROM
STORE TO STORE TO STORE IN ORDER
TO LOCATE A SINGLE CARTON WHICH
IS PROBABLY LOCKED BEHIND A
WINDOW BECAUSE OF RAMPANT
SHOPLIFTING.
AND THESE AMERICANS RETURN HOME
WITH A MORTGAGE THAT IS
UNDERWATER AND AN ELECTRIC BILL
THAT IS HIGHER THAN EVER.
THEN THEY TURN ON THE TV TO SEE
THEIR RETIREMENT FUNDS ARE
PLUMMETING, A CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, VIOLENT CRIME
AN EPIDEMIC IN ALMOST EVERY
MAJOR AMERICAN CITIES, CITIES
RUN BY LIBERAL DEMOCRATS BY
DECADES AND STATES THAT HAVE
BEEN RUN BY LIBERAL DEMOCRATS
FOR DECK ATES.
STATES THAT LIKE DEFUNDING,
DISMANTLING POLICE, STATES THAT
LIKE NO BAIL LAWS.
SO WHAT WE HAVE IS AN OLD
DECREPIT PRESIDENT CAN BARELY
SHUFFLE HIS FEET CAN'T READ A
TELL PROMPTER PREFERS A PHONEY
OVAL OFFICE TO THE REAL OVAL
OFFICE AND EVERYWHERE AMERICANS
ARE LOOKING, THEY ARE FACED WITH
THE REALITY EVERY SINGLE DAY OF
THE CONSEQUENCES OF ALL OF JOE
BIDEN'S POLICIES AND THE
FAILURES OF THOSE POLICIES.
THEY SEE A PRESIDENT WHO WILL
SOON BE HEADED TO SAUDI ARABIA
TO BEG THEM FOR MORE SNOWILY
INSTEAD OF PRODUCING THAT OIL
RIGHT HERE AT HOME?
THAT'S JOE'S PLAN TO BRING DOWN
GAS PRICES THAT'S IT?
OFFERING NO OTHER SOLUTIONS?
UNLESS YOU CONSIDER DOING A DEAL
WITHLE THE MULL AS IN IRAN THAT
WANT US DEAD OR IN THE MURDERING
THUG DICTATOR IN VENEZUELA
UNLESS YOU CONSIDER THAT A
SOLUTION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE IDEA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, CLICK A
SWITCH AND BRING DOWN THE COST
OF GASOLINE IS NOT LIKELY IN THE
NEAR TERM NOR IS IT WITH REGARD
TO FOOD.
>> Tucker: JUST LIKE JIMMY
CARTER PUT ON ON YOUR SWEATER
AND LOWER THE THERMOSTAT.
NOT ONLY IS HE SHORT ON
SOLUTIONS BUT HE REFUSES AS PER
USUAL TO TAKE ANY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR ANYTHING, NOT EVEN THE
INFLATION THAT HE, HIMSELF
CAUSED.
HIS POLICIES CAUSED.
HIS ECONOMIC POLICIES AND HIS
ENERGY POLICIES CAUSED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO
ADMIT YOU WERE WRONG ABOUT
INFLATION?
>> NO EASY QUESTIONS TODAY, HUH?
>> THE TREASURY SECRETARY SAYS
WHEN SHE WAS WRONG SO WHY
DOESN'T ANYBODY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> OKAY, SO, LOOK.
WHAT THE SECRETARY WAS POINTING
OUT, TALKING ABOUT YESTERDAY
WHEN SHE WAS DOING HER HIT WITH
HER TV HIT WITH CNN IS THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SHOCKS TO THE
ECONOMY THAT HAS EXACERBATED
INFLATION AREA PRECIOUS WHICH
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN FORSEEN 18
MONTHS AGO.
>> WHY NOT?
>> I'M TRYING TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
HOLD ON.
I WAS JUST GETTING TO THE WHY
NOT.
INCLUDING RUSSIAN'S DECISION TO
INVADE UKRAINE.
MULTIPLE AS YOU CAN SEE I HAVE
VARIANTS OF COVID AND LOCKDOWNS
IN CHINA.
>> Sean: ACCORDING TO JOE'S OWN
ADMINISTRATION JOE BIDEN CAN DO
NO WRONG AND BASED ON TONIGHT'S
SPEECH THE PRESIDENT IS DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT GUN CONTROL AND
YET HE CAN'T EVEN BE BOTHERED TO
STICK AROUND IN THE DC SWAMP
THIS WEEKEND AND BROKER A DEAL
ON CAPITOL HILL.
LOOK.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT THINKS
CONGRESS MUST ACT IMMEDIATELY TO
END THIS EPIDEMIC OF GUN
VIOLENCE IS HE GOING TO BRING
ANY OF THE KEY PLAYERS FROM
CAPITOL HILL WITH HIM TO THE
BEACH TONIGHT?
>> OH, OKAY.
>> BIG PART OF HIS CAMPAIGN
WHOLE THING IS HE KNOWS HOW TO
GET THINGS DONE.
>> IT IS.
>> I'M ASKING WHY YOU WANT TO
GET THESE NEGOTIATIONS.
>> DO YOU WANT TO GO TO THE
BEACH WITH THE PRESIDENT
TONIGHT?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO.
>>THE TOUCHE' LIKE THAT, THE
WEATHER, IT IS POURING OUTSIDE
LIKE CATS AND DOGS.
IT IS NOT GREAT.
>> PEOPLE ARE DYING EVERY DAY,
WHY SHOULD THIS PRESIDENT THEN
SAY HE WANTS TO GIVE SUBMIT
SPACE AND LET SOMEBODY ELSE --
>> BUT YOU'RE ALSO GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT.
>> Sean: IT'S SO URGENT HE'S NOT
STICKING AROUND BECAUSE ALL OF
THIS IS POLITICAL THEATER.
THAT'S WHY HE NEVER MENTIONED
THE MURDERS THAT TOOK PLACE
UNDER HIS WATCH AND OBAMA'S
WATCH AND OBAMA'S HOME CITY OF
CHICAGO.
IT'S ALL THEATER.
IT'S ANOTHER SHAMELESS ATTEMPT
TO VILIFY POLITICAL OPPONENTS
AND IT'S AGAIN FEIGNED MORAL
OUTRAGE BECAUSE OTHERWISE WOULD
YOU BE CONSISTENT YOU WOULD HAVE
SPOKEN OUT IN 2009 T10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16.
YOU WOULD HAVE SPOKEN OUT.
HE DIDN'T.
JOE BIDEN PROMISED TO BRING THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER AND UNIFY THE
COUNTRY.
THAT WAS A LIE.
HE PLEDGED TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR HIS ACTIONS
NOT BLAME OTHERS.
THAT TOO A BIG LIE.
HE PROMISED TO SHUT DOWN THE
VIRUS, RESTORE THE SOUL OF OUR
NATION.
WE HAD 100,000 NEW CASES OF
COVID TODAY, THAT WAS A LIE.
HE PROMISED TO NOT ABANDON
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN, YEAH,
TONY BLINKEN EVEN ADMITTED TWO
WEEKS AGO, YEAH, WE LEFT THEM
BEHIND.
ANOTHER LIE.
HE PROMISED THAT INFLATION WAS
TRANSITORY, TURNS OUT IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S ALMOST PERMANENT.
THAT WAS ANOTHER LIE.
HE PROMISED GAS PRICES WOULD
COME DOWN, ANOTHER LIE.
SO, JOE, IF YOU REALLY WANT TO
KNOW WHY YOUR POLL NUMBERS ARE
SO LOW, YOU KNOW, STOP BEING SO
MYSTIFIED AND SHOCKED AND
WONDERING AND PONDERING THE
GREAT MYSTERIES OF THE EARTH
HERE.
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED.
YOU'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING RIGHT.
YOU'RE NOT HELPING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND ALL YOU SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
IS GETTING AWAY FROM DC AND
GOING TO SLEEP AND TAKING YOUR
NAPS ON THE BEACH.
AMERICA DOESN'T TRUST HIM
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN SO HONEST
MORE IMPORTANTLY THEY DON'T
RESPECT HIM BECAUSE HIS POLICY
RESIST A DISASTER.
THEY DON'T, YOU KNOW, REVERE HIM
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE FAMILY'S
CORRUPT.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN HIM
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO.
AND THEY DON'T LIKE HIM BECAUSE
HE BLAMES EVERYTHING ON
EVERYBODY ELSE INCLUDING HIS OWN
STAFF.
AS THE NEW YORK POST MICHAEL
GOODWIN PUT IT, THE U.S. LOV